why is it that
winston churchill has been seen as a
racist but karl marx has been seen as a
hero yeah i'm so glad you asked that's
one of my favorite bug bears
um
uh
yeah
well
here's my short answer
uh there is an attempt to take down all
of our heroes
all of our heroes
winston churchill for the british is our
hero our national hero only 20 years ago
when we were allowed an opportunity to
vote on who the greatest britain was bbc
had this
bc documentary
10 people was when they ended up being
shortlisted i think and people presented
a program on each and the um
and the the person who won hands down as
the greatest briton of all time was
winston churchill of course
um
now in 2022 uh even the bbc whenever it
runs a piece by winston churchill has to
run like
the case for the for the um prosecution
right ten
terrible things winston churchill did
um they've decided he's been decided to
recast him in a different light and
again a very unfair light he's accused
of a lot of things he didn't do
such as
gassing uh iraqis in fact he and this is
a gnome chomsky like he actually
used not to get too much into the weeds
but
churchill ordered the use of what we
have now called tears
not mustard gas and chomsky and others
have pretended that he used must have
gas on the iraqis that lie has gone
around repeatedly there are other other
all sorts of other accusations against
churchill but basically it's because
um the british
love and admire winston churchill still
not everybody there are some critics
but by and large he is our biggest
national hero
and um
you know when the film finest hour came
out
you know there were lots of stories of
people
in cinemas at the end getting to their
feets and feet and doing standing
ovations
and
i mean i don't know if you feel this but
i feel very strongly that uh
churchill is it's it's not just about
him
um
in britain there's a view that
and i think it's correct that
the world would certainly have
um allowed nazism to flood across europe
and possibly to britain
if
churchill hadn't been in place at that
time
who was it that said this is the one
time i've seen the hand of god at work
in the real world yeah lord halesham
said it's one time i've seen the hand of
god
um operate in politics it felt like it
just the mo that
that that churchill being put into place
at that moment was just a godsend and it
was and the other thing is of course he
he
for all of our families in britain i
mean he was the rallying figure along
with the king and the queen
um
who showed the british people
the resilience necessary to sacrifice
their sons
a second time within a few decades
because he done what fought on six
continents or something or five
continents he'd put himself forward for
world war ii volunteered to fight in
world war one great
fantastic hats
smokes drank a lot um
but he represented and represents still
for a lot of us in britain this
a sense of what our spirit is which is
um a difficult belligerent unbowed
um uh dogged
um
not self-pitying
um
and much more
and
so why have they come for churchill
i explain it the ways in which they've
come for him but my answer as to why is
because they know that it will
demoralize us
who are they
the people who hate the west in general
who hate britain who hate america
if you take down they hate people like
churchill being admired
they can't bear it because they know
that it's something so deep within us
now what is that deep thing for me and i
think for a lot of other british people
it is
the sense
that we're a good country
that we did something good
that
france may have given in
that
with the only shots fired being against
french soldiers by french soldiers but
as good as a cross over that
uh you know the dutch
rolled over
a lot of other countries didn't have a
choice and so on and so forth but the
british wouldn't and this is because we
were a good country and we faced up to
bad people when we saw them
that is a very very important
feeling nationally but if you want to
stop the british feeling pride in
themselves you've got to take out
winston churchill
in the same way in america
if you hate america you not only hate
the fact that founding fathers are
revered and they've been my god as i say
in the chapter on history they've really
come for the founding fathers in recent
years
now you might say again there's a
historical revisionism that was needed
uh
60 years ago people in america who
revered jefferson say didn't necessarily
know he was a slave owner
we know today it'd be nice to know
something other than the fact he was a
slave owner
but the point is if you attack the
founding fathers you attack an idea of
america if you take down lincoln
the victor of the civil war
and that's also happening
literally this and i've seen themselves
with statues of lincoln torn down in
america
if you tear down lincoln
you go in a similar way to attack the
foundation of america because if you
don't have lincoln you basically don't
have america and again not just because
he was a good man
who won the civil war
and
and
and
did this extraordinary thing
not just because of that but also
because his whole story was a story of
coming from nothing
and becoming president
i mean he grew up in
absolute poverty lincoln probably had
one year of formal education everything
else he was self-taught
he taught himself to read books
he was a remarkable man
who imbued a spirit of america which
many americans still feel but if you
take down lincoln
you've taken down the idea of america
now sorry one other point the quick
point on that why don't they do it to
marx
ah
well
the same remorseless battle is the same
remorseless attack is made
on every historical figure in the west
on every philosopher of the west every
cultural hero of the west
and it's always done the same way they
lived in a time of slavery and did
something to endorse it or didn't work
against it enough they lived in a time
of colonialism and didn't attack it
enough or benefited from it in some way
they were racist by modern standards
this is done against everybody everybody
in american history and in british
history in western history except for
karl marx
what a coincidence is this
um
i i took great delight searching the
book of finding out the the many many
racist things that karl marx said
in his private letters private letters
to engles he constantly uses yen word
often uh linked to jew profoundly
anti-semitic of course
extraordinarily bad views on slavery on
colonialism
everything else
he said much more racist things than any
of the people that we've discussed
discussed so far including churchill
and yet weirdly he doesn't get the same
treatment
so if you take out every thinker
other than karl marx
why would that be
other than that you're not really just
you're not really carrying out a fair
critique you're carrying out a
deliberately unfair critique in order to
advance an existing cause
the existing cause in this case is
anything but westernism and marxism is
one of the answers
and i'm afraid that anti-westernism has
always been um whipped along by marxism
ever since the benighted birth of karl
marx
um
he
uh
even in the post-colonial era as i say
in the books but one of the great
ironies of the postcolonial era
is that
anti-colonialists like fanart who i
write about all said we've got to get
rid of western rule in africa
now you could say well
at this point we must return africa to a
pre-colonial time a kind of native
tradition
which would have included all sorts of
traditions which would also not look
very nice in the light of modern thought
um
the obar of benin was not a liberal
democrat and uh much more anyway but the
point you you that they didn't say that
they people like fanon said we must get
the europeans out of uh africa and stop
the european colonialism and capitalism
in order that we can institute western
marxism
well
this is an oddity at the very least but
as i say i think it's one of these
things the fact that people don't apply
this standard to certain people and do
to others is a demonstration that they
are engaging in a bad faith argument
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you